[SPEAKER_03]: Hang on.
[SPEAKER_03]: We'll go there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Second Whale Sun, probably around, eh, after 430, a little bit after 430, the marine unit is bloody.
[SPEAKER_03]: Basically, um...
[SPEAKER_03]: The hobgoblins fire bolts into the men that were downed in the yard, which are three men.
[SPEAKER_03]: They do not let them survive.
[SPEAKER_03]: They do not let anybody go out of the tower and retrieve them.
[SPEAKER_03]: So three of the marines of your squad of 20 have been killed.
[SPEAKER_03]: 17 left.
[SPEAKER_03]: None of your archers have been wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, many of you have been wounded.
[SPEAKER_03]: The archers take up positions on the second floor, ready to fire on anybody that comes back, but they are hiding themselves so as not to be fired at as well.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's kind of a strange...
[SPEAKER_02]: It's almost like a volley here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's kind of like a strange sort of stalemate at this time.
[SPEAKER_03]: On the other side, able to leave the protections of whatever building they're in.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is this dude dead or is he down?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, does anybody want to keep him alive?
[SPEAKER_01]: Does anybody speak hobgoblin?
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: We can't say anything.
[SPEAKER_01]: Actually, what we're gonna do is survival roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: First one.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's good.
[SPEAKER_03]: Second one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Third one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bad.
[SPEAKER_03]: Fourth one.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's good.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's alive, and the sergeant takes him prisoner.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, they dispatch the rest.
[SPEAKER_00]: So this guy's gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: The one that we pushed up against the wall there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's there too.
[SPEAKER_00]: The big guy's still alive.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, basically you, the four of you come down into the area where the sergeant is and he has patrols there.
[SPEAKER_03]: What do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: If there's still two guys up there, I want to climb that wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: You want to go right now or do you want to, how many hit points do you have?
[SPEAKER_03]: I've got 3 left.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got 5, 10, 15, 20, 24.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got 34 left.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to say a battle plan.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want everybody to come together real quick.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, where are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Are you up here with me or are you downstairs?
[SPEAKER_02]: He's downstairs.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I'm on the second floor.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's on the second floor.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's up here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm up there, but I'm inside this area right now.
[SPEAKER_03]: So what Tyrus has done is he's put archers here and archers here, but they're laying low.
[SPEAKER_03]: So the eight archers that are not, you or you, are there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to stick my head out and I'm going to say, we need a plan.
[SPEAKER_02]: So come in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like, come in here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd rather get rid of the ones up top.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's do this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Let's make a plan to do it, though.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Here's this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to go up the ladder.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to bang on the door to turn their attention to the door.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to go around the side away from the archers and climb the wall over.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so whoever can climb the wall can climb the wall, but I'm going to turn their attention to the door should give you an opportunity to do something.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where are you going to go?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll do the same on the opposite side.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, because there's archers over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm coming around this side.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you want to try, come around over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I wouldn't even try.
[SPEAKER_01]: I can go up there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You can climb walls?
[SPEAKER_04]: Anybody can with athletics.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Whatever.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I'll go back inside and go with the other side.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're not our strongest combat.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've still got the flute thing, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that six rounds or something?
[SPEAKER_02]: So it's still going.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm going to go back and sign with the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you go on to the sergeant to talk to him.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to start scaling, but I'm going to stay below the wall until I hear banging.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are you going to do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Up here, start scaling.
[SPEAKER_01]: Go back here, right here, whatever one.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll go back.
[SPEAKER_00]: You don't want to be over here or over here anyway.
[SPEAKER_00]: You want to be on any one of those.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be on this side.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Gouge, you're going to be on this side.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Climb the wall and just take in my shield and just like hammer it.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you're just banging on the thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: With my shield up above me, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that I've... All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: So we can't... Nobody can see them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we got no idea what's going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I just know there's a couple guys, at least a couple up there, because they were still shooting.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so the two of you climb up to the edge of the wall, and do you want to just go over it, or do you want to stealth and listen, or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I climb quicker than him, or do we climb basically the same, because of my skills?
[SPEAKER_03]: You are not what's called a thief, you're an assassin, so you're climbing that's not double speed.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck.
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to go over stealthy, because I don't even want a volley of arrows coming this way if they see somebody up on top.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm going to try to come up as stealthy as I can to go over.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, first round, you're going to use Dash to climb up?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: 30 feet?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: How about you?
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going to climb up as fast as you can.
[SPEAKER_03]: As fast as I can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Athletics check.
[SPEAKER_02]: 20 sided.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirteen plus whatever I got on a six, nineteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven plus two.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you guys both climb to the top.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then the next round, you want to try and stealth over or do you just want to climb over the top?
[SPEAKER_02]: I want to try to stealth over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, that stealthing is
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, it's not an action.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's hiding.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, so you try to stealth over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll yourself a roll.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which is a 20.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I guess we're stealth.
[SPEAKER_02]: I get plus six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you come to here and you're just gonna try and climb over?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm gonna just try to climb over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you climb over.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, you totally can.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to do that after you come over?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so you run up to here and yell at them and you see these two guys standing right there and there.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're hobgoblins, correct?
[SPEAKER_01]: Correct.
[SPEAKER_01]: They're basically hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_01]: Speak any.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or common tongue or anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you want to say something to them in common?
[SPEAKER_01]: I just want to say yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Surrender.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have the tower taken.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're basically standing there with their long swords out.
[SPEAKER_03]: One says to you in common, broken common, we surrender.
[SPEAKER_03]: He throws his sword down as Gouge crawls over the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Go ahead.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what's gonna happen?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna attack.
[SPEAKER_02]: Whatever the round is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Rolling it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nine plus four.
[SPEAKER_02]: Thirteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven.
[SPEAKER_01]: Eleven plus three, uh, fourteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so Gouge rushes forward with his blade and attacks the plus one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eleven plus nine is twenty.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: One die six plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so he goes up there and slashes the hobgoblin, does not kill him, but wounds him badly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Your turn.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, I draw my, uh...
[SPEAKER_01]: Rapier, Buckler, and I attack the other one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Roll your attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Thirteen, plus five.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eighteen, one die eight.
[SPEAKER_01]: One plus three, four.
[SPEAKER_01]: Four?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a line that allows them to do that?
[SPEAKER_01]: When someone's surrendered?
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not the best.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I saw you attack, it's basically in the heat of battle, but that's like, I'm gonna have your back.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm not gonna just, like, he surrendered, like, your attack, so I'm like, he's gonna...
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gonna kill him.
[SPEAKER_01]: You're deuce.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's all I'm gonna say right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm kinda douchey.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I did nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: And you did a four, seven.
[SPEAKER_00]: I didn't roll a one.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, you rolled a three.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You did nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: He did nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, nine.
[SPEAKER_00]: You rolled a three plus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, um...
[SPEAKER_03]: They draw their daggers.
[SPEAKER_03]: One attacks you.
[SPEAKER_03]: 16, 17, 18, 19, 19.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's gonna be a hit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Motherfucker.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's four points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: One draws his dagger and attacks you.
[SPEAKER_03]: 13, 14, 15, 16.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's your AC?
[SPEAKER_03]: 17 because my buckler's out.
[SPEAKER_03]: You block it with your buckler.
[SPEAKER_03]: Very close attack.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, I guess.
[SPEAKER_02]: 14.
[SPEAKER_02]: They get a 3.
[SPEAKER_02]: 10.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm pulling the dagger too.
[SPEAKER_02]: Attack on him.
[SPEAKER_02]: 7.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I don't think that bard thing will help, will it?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm gonna use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's 16, you hit him anyway.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, I did?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And do you want to stick attack him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or, he looks pretty bad off, maybe you could use the dagger on the other guy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I mean, I already, I thought I would have dropped him with that last one, so I will, uh, definitely.
[SPEAKER_02]: One plus six.
[SPEAKER_02]: Seven.
[SPEAKER_02]: That kills him.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you want to backstab the guy that's on that guy?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, roll.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's not anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fifteen.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's a hit.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's a four-sided.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you want to use your backstab?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Steak attack, I mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Which is?
[SPEAKER_03]: Three, six seconds, nice.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that is?
[SPEAKER_03]: Six, seven, eight, nine.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nine points of damage.
[SPEAKER_03]: He basically stabs the guy in the back that you're fighting and do for.
[SPEAKER_03]: Gouge is, or Aracel is very fast and very deft with his blades.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who on the mean side?
[SPEAKER_03]: And Pete to fuck.
[SPEAKER_03]: Those two guys are gone and there are four dead hobgoblins on top.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I'm beating on the frickin' thing.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can we open the hatch?
[SPEAKER_01]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's open the hatch and go down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'm gonna kick the hatch three times and say, clear.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Right?
[SPEAKER_02]: And then pop the bolt.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Up to the top.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're right.
[SPEAKER_02]: So wait, you're coming up, I'm gonna say, stay low, we've got archers from there and I don't know if they can fire on us.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm gonna go lean against this wall in here and lay down.
[SPEAKER_00]: How would I signal to the ship that there's a problem?
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, so you get to the top of the tower and usually there is like a lamp, a brazier that you can
[SPEAKER_03]: Bring up and put stuff in it, fire in it, and then you can save it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are we at the top of the south tower?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: You are at the top of, not the south lighthouse, but the guard tower, which you can see out over the bay.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, you see the ship coming into the bay over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right?
[SPEAKER_03]: All right.
[SPEAKER_03]: But the signal fire is not there.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Bust out, tender, box.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to send an arrow, a flaming arrow of some kind off of this towards the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who's got the best bow, weapon, something?
[SPEAKER_00]: We need a signal of some kind of flaming arrow of some kind.
[SPEAKER_02]: You got a longbow probably?
[SPEAKER_02]: Longbow's gonna out-shoot a heavy crossbow on distance?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, by about 200 feet.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we get some kind of flaming arrow of some kind to fire towards the ship, from there towards the ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: Just in that direction?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, hopefully to see, you know...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm trying to think anything, I gotta... Yeah, yeah, I mean we need to signal somehow to the ship.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you have some of your red eye.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do have a tinder box of some kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thanks for fucking reminding me.
[SPEAKER_02]: One time, I wish I was a heavy drinker.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'd get some of them hits back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Those are imaginary hit points, by the way, and they go away after that.
[SPEAKER_03]: I need to die.
[SPEAKER_02]: I feel good.
[SPEAKER_00]: A knock to the head did something to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we do something like that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I mean, if you guys want to get an arrow ready to fire.
[SPEAKER_03]: We should narrow it up.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, what exactly are you trying to say?
[SPEAKER_00]: Obviously, if there's
[SPEAKER_00]: If we fire upon the ship, like, he can't hit the ship from there.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, that's way too far away.
[SPEAKER_00]: Way too far.
[SPEAKER_00]: But, if he fires something from... That's a thousand feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're about two thousand feet about from where the ship will be docking.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, but if he fires a flaming arrow into the air, it's obviously going to be something
[SPEAKER_00]: Not normal.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't know... Oh, you're up here.
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't know...
[SPEAKER_02]: If we got a captain and anybody on that fucking ship worth a shit, they've got their fucking eyeglass out and they're witnessing this fucking velvet.
[SPEAKER_00]: That elf is smart.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't give him more credit than he fucking deserves, but yeah, he should be able to pick this up.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, light some shit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fucking fire off
[SPEAKER_02]: Three of them.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got eight.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't want to use any more than I have.
[SPEAKER_00]: Too bad.
[SPEAKER_00]: We need to keep it safe.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, hold on then.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, we're not reaching anything.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I got a ton of bolts left.
[SPEAKER_02]: Keep your arrows because you were going to need them.
[SPEAKER_02]: So here.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I hand out six bolts.
[SPEAKER_02]: I said, start wrapping and start fucking lighting them and I'm just going to start shooting them out towards the ship.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll see what happens.
[SPEAKER_03]: Three of them.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know this is not standard Monmurian signaling.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, you're a signal professional.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like flaming arrows.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's not a signal.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm also not in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm with the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's right.
[SPEAKER_03]: I apologize.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, you guys have no idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: I've sailed and done this a lot.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know this is not standard, Monmurian.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I do a check of what the fuck I should do?
[SPEAKER_02]: Would it be an obvious thing like, this is what I need to do?
[SPEAKER_03]: I will let you do an insight check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plus four.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sixteen.
[SPEAKER_03]: You need a colored flame.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm going to holler down to the bottom to the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do we signal the ship?
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm going to say we need a fucking colored flame.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You hear that.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the sergeant says to you, I'm feeling a little rough right now, Folsom.
[SPEAKER_03]: Could you go up there and tell those fools how to signal the ship?
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, don't worry.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I climb out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I said, guys, we need a colored flame.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I know that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where the fuck do we get it?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Come on, kid.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm gonna whip out my entertainers pack and just start digging through it to see if there's anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So... You got some phosphorus on hand?
[SPEAKER_03]: The entertainers kit.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's actually not a bad kit to have.
[SPEAKER_03]: DC-15.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you will find some chemicals that could be used to make some kind of a colored, not explosive, but signal.
[SPEAKER_03]: Or some materials for it.
[SPEAKER_04]: A DC-15.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do any of my skills up it at all?
[SPEAKER_04]: Nature.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nature?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that even a thing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nurture.
[SPEAKER_04]: Nature or nurture?
[SPEAKER_04]: It's a 14 plus 2, with my nature is 16.
[SPEAKER_04]: Alright, you've got some phosphorus.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now if you have like some metal shavings, you could do something that would be like a green or a red.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you need some more materials.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, my sword?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can I take it, scrape something off the side of my sword or something?
[SPEAKER_00]: Or not my sword.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll grab one of their swords and start scraping some stuff off.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have a mess kit, which is basically a dish or a bowl of some kind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Lightweight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pull out my mess kit.
[SPEAKER_00]: And used my sword against their... Scraped some kind of a metal maybe?
[SPEAKER_00]: My back...
[SPEAKER_02]: I imagine I got a backpack.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a disguise kit and a poisoner's kit in here.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's in your poisoner's kit?
[SPEAKER_02]: So I pull those out for... the kit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, any of this shit, rate of color.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where is it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Aerocell pulls off this weird stuff, and much of it looks actually very, very dangerous and deadly.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nature, DC-10, and you can find some kind of a chemical or compound that can be used to interact with the phosphorus.
[SPEAKER_03]: 18.
[SPEAKER_03]: Wow.
[SPEAKER_03]: So you find some nickel grindings.
[SPEAKER_03]: That actually, if you put together with this phosphorus and set it on fire, it will make this sort of bluish flame.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anything left of that brazier that we can use bigger than mine?
[SPEAKER_00]: The brazier's not there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, it's not there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I think you got it, kid.
[SPEAKER_04]: I can sure as hell try.
[SPEAKER_04]: The ship is docking!
[SPEAKER_04]: Get it up!
[SPEAKER_02]: Light the fucker and put it on here and I'm gonna shoot it up that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright, so you basically take a cloth and put it in the mess kit and pour red eye on it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not all of it, kid!
[SPEAKER_03]: You put the potsher in the nickel things, nickel filings, and then take it out, and before it dries, you wrap it around the crossbow.
[SPEAKER_03]: I got my tinderbox out, I'll light it.
[SPEAKER_03]: They sink flames.
[SPEAKER_03]: Alright.
[SPEAKER_03]: The bolt arches with the smoky but bluish flame out over the Azure Sea in the direction of where they are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now, I assume you want to shoot it more up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Not down.
[SPEAKER_04]: I want hang time.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right into the water.
[SPEAKER_04]: Psst.
[SPEAKER_04]: Goes out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: When I shoot it, I want it this far from that guy's ear.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's lighting at you, and you go... and fire it.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, it streaks up into the sky, and to all of you, that seems extremely useful.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're smart enough to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm watching the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it continue to dock?
[SPEAKER_00]: Does it peel off?
[SPEAKER_00]: What happens?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, actually, what happens is...
[SPEAKER_02]: I stay down on the low.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let me know.
[SPEAKER_03]: A flare is fired back at you, acknowledging the fact they've received your signal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah!
[SPEAKER_00]: I freakin' grab the kid!
[SPEAKER_00]: Good job, kid.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the ship goes into the docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: What?!
[SPEAKER_00]: I throw the kid!
[SPEAKER_04]: Maybe you celebrated too early there, Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_02]: Fuck, over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so they know, or at least they're aware that there's a problem.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: You watch.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what happens is, from this distance you can see that a squad of marines are allowed to disembark.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you can't, you're not really sure, but I think from the
[SPEAKER_03]: Reflection of the sun off of the mask, Paul Rivero is with the squad.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, that's fantastic.
[SPEAKER_03]: As they begin marching up the docks.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's not fantastic.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that's just great.
[SPEAKER_02]: We're supposed to fucking watch that guy.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is fucking fan-fucking-tastic.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Down to the bottom.
[SPEAKER_02]: You don't fly ass if that kid gets fucked up.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, I didn't.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, now you do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Down to the bottom, and I look at him and I go, it's probably all our asses that kid gets fucked up.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna obviously tell the sergeant everything that just happened, what we did, how fucking badass we were, and what's happened here.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that we have to... That's a lot to cover.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pretty much everyone understands that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: What do you say to them?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, I'm going to tell them that we let the flare
[SPEAKER_00]: That they acknowledged it, yet they still docked, and they still fucking dumped off Marines, and that the- Terris, I don't see what we're going to be able to do here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Right, we need to move.
[SPEAKER_03]: If we walk out of this door, the hobgoblins, and Terris is getting off on the dock over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Easy enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're gonna go out, the second floor,
[SPEAKER_02]: We're going to leave these guys here in a very diplomatic knot.
[SPEAKER_00]: My suggestion, Sergeant, would be we leave some guys here and leave them as a distraction for the rest of these here.
[SPEAKER_00]: The rest of us scale off the side of this wall and make our way to the docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look at yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're wounded.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm healed.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm good to go, Sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: I am good to go.
[SPEAKER_00]: How many points do you have left?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm back to full health.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you're back to full health.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, lay off hands and put me back to full health.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, you got fucking marks out there with all those archers in the other fucking tower.
[SPEAKER_00]: That would be my suggestion, Sergeant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have a better plan?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because we can run along this here.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are we talking here?
[SPEAKER_00]: We're talking.
[SPEAKER_03]: Our order for to take the barracks here.
[SPEAKER_03]: I think that that's our next move is to attack the barracks.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I tell him, if we take the barracks, but Paul, what's it?
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero dies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is our mission complete?
[SPEAKER_00]: You tell me, Sergeant.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't see how we can do anything about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's just a long ways.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, that would take... We're almost a mile away from the docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Which would... We ran a four-minute mile.
[SPEAKER_00]: What are we gonna run in a month?
[SPEAKER_03]: It would take us at least 20 minutes to help.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has 200 marines on that quest.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: The captain has made his decision.
[SPEAKER_03]: There's nothing we can do about it for now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just get some rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: You watch as the detachment marines walk down the pier towards the Quays.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of a sudden, there are more soldiers on the top of the quays attacking Paul Ribeiro and the unit down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Crossbows.
[SPEAKER_03]: We see?
[SPEAKER_03]: Firing at each other.
[SPEAKER_03]: You two are watching it happen.
[SPEAKER_03]: You see them attack Paul Ribeiro's unit.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the other map?
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the map?
[SPEAKER_02]: The little one?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, sorry.
[SPEAKER_02]: My bad.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: You guys are right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, we're way the fuck over here.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're landing on what dock?
[SPEAKER_02]: The close one?
[SPEAKER_02]: The far one.
[SPEAKER_00]: You said it's going to take us 20 minutes to get there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And they're hobgoblin and it's right there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Covering the bridge.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're pretty much fucking pinned.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of a sudden you see a flame alight on the hobgoblins across here.
[SPEAKER_03]: A magical flame spring up.
[SPEAKER_02]: Alright, we got some fucking magic user doing some weird shit that will buy us some time maybe.
[SPEAKER_02]: Keep your eye on that.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any way we can get our archers or something to engage, to take away, where we can come?
[SPEAKER_02]: You know the terrain extremely well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a way we can get coverage and get out past if we have our men engage?
[SPEAKER_02]: If we can have our men engage the barracks, can we sneak?
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there a way we can get around under cover?
[SPEAKER_02]: To start heading that way.
[SPEAKER_03]: A secret way to get here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is there a secret way to get from here to there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Folsum, as you watch the battle, you see strange man-shaped fish people crawling out of the ocean onto the docks and the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hundreds of them attacking the ship.
[SPEAKER_03]: And a battle on the ship ensues.
[SPEAKER_03]: Uh, guys?
[SPEAKER_04]: You're gonna want to take a look down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I see it?
[SPEAKER_03]: You look down there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Merrick, it's definitely sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_03]: They're attacking the ship in the Bay of the Helms, something that hasn't happened in hundreds of years.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I can't believe it.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm like, shook.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're talking hundreds of them in the realm of 400, 600, more, swarming the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: A ball of fire erupts on this fortification.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you see the first squad of marines be able to reach the top of the quay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Then they disappear.
[SPEAKER_03]: However... Our marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Your marines, the ones with Paul Ribeiro.
[SPEAKER_03]: However, the boat seems to become overwhelmed with these shark men.
[SPEAKER_03]: Like fucking ants.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I see his disbelief?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What the fuck's going on with those?
[SPEAKER_01]: So Sogwin, I thought they went extinct years and years ago.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can they fucking fight on land?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can they get up here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can they attack?
[SPEAKER_02]: Can they move on land?
[SPEAKER_03]: I want you to roll, and you get advantage on this because they're your hated enemy.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have a survival check to know about Hoggan and all their stuff.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Two 20s?
[SPEAKER_03]: Two 20s and take the best one.
[SPEAKER_03]: 17, 17 plus 6.
[SPEAKER_03]: So Hoggan can exist on
[SPEAKER_03]: Land, but only for four hours.
[SPEAKER_03]: Otherwise, they suffocate.
[SPEAKER_03]: So they can go out, but the truth is this.
[SPEAKER_03]: They hate leaving the beaches.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, they would very rarely ever go up onto this land.
[SPEAKER_03]: They would do it if they were desperate, but they'd have to be very desperate to do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like forced to do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: We gotta stay away from the coast.
[SPEAKER_01]: Coastline, if possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: We need to stay.
[SPEAKER_01]: All right.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to head back up the ladder.
[SPEAKER_01]: Going back to our boat or anything is besides the point of this.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not doing that.
[SPEAKER_03]: Somebody looks down and goes, I don't think we can go back to our boats.
[SPEAKER_03]: Look.
[SPEAKER_02]: We look.
[SPEAKER_02]: What do we see?
[SPEAKER_02]: Sahagin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Taking your boats and basically taking them out to sea.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're getting overrun.
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to support
[SPEAKER_02]: We have to support them over there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know if they've got the men, uh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: This bottom line is we need to be there to help.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm gonna say, who knows what about everything about this?
[SPEAKER_00]: Who's got everything, who's got information about this mission?
[SPEAKER_00]: Spill it now.
[SPEAKER_00]: We're in deep fucking shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anything you know, we all need to know.
[SPEAKER_02]: The kid with the mask
[SPEAKER_02]: Politically he needs to be protected.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay?
[SPEAKER_02]: If it comes down to us living or dying, fuck him.
[SPEAKER_02]: But our number one priority is to keep him alive right now.
[SPEAKER_02]: And the magic users that's with him can hold his own, but if not, fucking help him too.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick, spill the fucking beans.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know you know shit, make it happen.
[SPEAKER_01]: I know what he knows of the new political protect him, but also there is
[SPEAKER_01]: Some type of magic that's been happening here on this island that we're actually here to investigate.
[SPEAKER_01]: Something has been going wrong that was needed.
[SPEAKER_01]: We didn't want to tell everyone else because we didn't want to freak out.
[SPEAKER_02]: So the fog is magic-based.
[SPEAKER_02]: Everything's magic-based.
[SPEAKER_02]: This place is fucked that we're on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Nobody believes it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: But it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: A mysterious fog kind of took over this whole place a few days ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nothing that I've ever seen before in my whole time of being a ranger out on the sea.
[SPEAKER_01]: So it's not just those fucking shark creatures.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's somebody in there that works with shit too.
[SPEAKER_02]: And unless we can get to them and combine and have a solid force... One of the Marines looks at you and says, You're drunk!
[SPEAKER_03]: Not yet.
[SPEAKER_03]: But I will be.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're talking nonsense.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I haven't seen the Sogwin in years.
[SPEAKER_01]: I thought was it killed my dad?
[SPEAKER_03]: I assume.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, your father was killed, supposedly, by the Sohagin.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sohagin, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: I like the way you say it, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sogwin.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't mind that.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the Oridian way of saying it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's like a slur.
[SPEAKER_00]: Uh, so...
[SPEAKER_00]: I need fish people bad.
[SPEAKER_04]: I need to protect him.
[SPEAKER_04]: I get pissed and just, like, start, like, practicing, like, my...
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm on my, uh... You're anxious.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm anxious, I'm just practicing the fingers on my beef.
[SPEAKER_04]: Just, like, just going back and forth just like this.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, this bridge... You got any children to play?
[SPEAKER_03]: Can he hold some fucking wounds?
[SPEAKER_03]: No, not for you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, I'm gonna ask the question, who is wounded?
[SPEAKER_03]: I am not.
[SPEAKER_03]: You're not, you're not, you're not, you are.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now here are the rules on short rests.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can take a short rest three times a day, three times, and it takes an hour to do a short rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you do a short rest, you can roll
[SPEAKER_03]: Your rest dice, as many as you want, that you have.
[SPEAKER_03]: So for you, you have six die eight rest die.
[SPEAKER_03]: If you start a short rest, you can start by rolling a first die and saying, I get four plus my con bonus back.
[SPEAKER_03]: You would get six hit points back.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you keep rolling that if you wanted to until you rolled all six die.
[SPEAKER_03]: You could save dice for other short rests later on that day.
[SPEAKER_03]: After you've rolled all your die, or if you've taken three short rests and not used them all, you have to take long rests before you can do the next thing.
[SPEAKER_03]: You can do it again.
[SPEAKER_03]: All of you have your die there.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we have six die.
[SPEAKER_03]: He has six.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've got one.
[SPEAKER_03]: You've got one die ten because you're a first-level paladin.
[SPEAKER_03]: You have the one die ten because you're a first-level ranger.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you get one die eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: When you become a second-level bard, you get two die eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: So it's basically set to the levels you are.
[SPEAKER_03]: So if you guys want to do a one-hour rest, you can get back hit points.
[SPEAKER_00]: Men and your group that are damaged can also get back hit points as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so we have to take a rest here.
[SPEAKER_00]: But while we're doing this, we need to make some sort of plan.
[SPEAKER_00]: We'll start a rest.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because we've got to figure, talk with the sergeant, talk with Merrick, who knows the island, and see if there's... Alright, so you get the sergeant to come up and you tell him the situation.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's looking at the boat getting overrun.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: The sergeant says, what do you know?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, so...
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Ribeiro needs to be protected for political reasons.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are not running the supplies.
[SPEAKER_01]: We're not doing any type of... We're on recon.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do we know where Paul Ribeiro went?
[SPEAKER_03]: You said he was attacked.
[SPEAKER_03]: He's on the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes, he was on the ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: The ship is now completely overrun.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have lost both ships.
[SPEAKER_01]: We are not going anywhere.
[SPEAKER_01]: Sahagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was on the dock.
[SPEAKER_00]: He got off the dock with 200 Marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Got up the dock with 200 marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: He got up the dock with a squad of marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: Squad of marines.
[SPEAKER_03]: There were 200 marines on the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: On the 200 marines in the boat.
[SPEAKER_03]: That are all gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Squad of marines.
[SPEAKER_00]: The squad of marines went in, lots of fire from a magic user.
[SPEAKER_00]: We believe that Paul is with them on the... We saw him get off the ship, didn't we?
[SPEAKER_03]: So he could possibly be on the quay somewhere.
[SPEAKER_00]: So he could possibly be on land.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you think he would go to the helm?
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think he would stay at the beach.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would think he would move inward somewhere.
[SPEAKER_00]: And we cannot get back to our ships because they're gone.
[SPEAKER_00]: The magic user, the elf, was with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: We saw fireballs, a lot of stuff going on there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I know any safe passage?
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, the fog?
[SPEAKER_03]: Any safe passage where?
[SPEAKER_01]: To try to get to here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, so you could take the bridge across, that's the safest way.
[SPEAKER_03]: Especially when the tide is in, because the waters underneath the bridge fill up.
[SPEAKER_03]: When the tide's out, it's like a beach, but if the tide is in, they fill up.
[SPEAKER_03]: And you'd be afraid of the fishmen being in that area or being able to have access to it.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, you'd probably be afraid of that anyway, even with the tide being out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Because they're all right on the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: They just won't go up a little higher.
[SPEAKER_03]: They would be fine there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we gotta keep on the bridge, I think.
[SPEAKER_03]: Now the problem with the bridge, of course, is the fact that the garrison, at least when you first start going that direction, they'll have a straight shot through to you.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's the road that goes to the bridge.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: And those are the guys that are still alive there on that garrison.
[SPEAKER_02]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: What if we...
[SPEAKER_01]: I feel like there's a few things we can do here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Either we send people out to battle...
[SPEAKER_01]: The ones in the hut here or the house to distract them and try to take a group towards this way.
[SPEAKER_01]: But I don't know if we should split up because we've got a lot of us.
[SPEAKER_00]: We should get a handful of archers up here that could keep these guys.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, I'm saying put all the archers on the row right here.
[SPEAKER_02]: Let's climb down, get some rope or something, climb down this side so we're not coming out vulnerable.
[SPEAKER_02]: And as soon as we start going out, we see their archers have our archers fire on them and just make a fucking run for them.
[SPEAKER_03]: Where are we going?
[SPEAKER_03]: Where is anyone going to go?
[SPEAKER_02]: Who do we know that's here?
[SPEAKER_02]: Paul Rivera is there, right?
[SPEAKER_02]: Do we know that?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, he's on the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: They landed here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, they landed here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: So he's either going to try and make the helm or he's going to try to make the barracks.
[SPEAKER_03]: Right.
[SPEAKER_03]: The question is...
[SPEAKER_02]: We don't know which way he's going.
[SPEAKER_03]: He was attacked from up here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is the helm even ours now?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I don't think anything on this place is ours.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, yeah, we don't own anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Paul Ribeiro made it to the barracks or not, we have no place to go.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'd have to fight our way in.
[SPEAKER_02]: And without enough men as bodies to sacrifice, it would be our bodies being sacrificed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Unless we could go with stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm saying wait, if we can hold here till nightfall?
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, it's what, four, five, getting towards five?
[SPEAKER_03]: The sun sets at seven.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you think after nightfall you could make it to the barracks and see if it's held by our forces or by theirs?
[SPEAKER_01]: I could definitely do that.
[SPEAKER_02]: All by yourself?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I could go with him.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would be stealthy enough to be able to go with him and follow him if he led through it.
[SPEAKER_02]: That would give me a couple hours of
[SPEAKER_02]: of regaining some fuckin' health here.
[SPEAKER_02]: And I can protect them on that way as long as you guys can hold this versus anyone coming up.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't think them shark people are gonna fuckin' come up here because they said they don't like it but we've got that other side you gotta keep a fuckin' eye on.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think that's the best idea.
[SPEAKER_03]: Just the two of you.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's very strange to me that these dogmen are here.
[SPEAKER_03]: And what's strange to me is, look at the weaponry and armor they wear.
[SPEAKER_03]: It looks as if it's made by our own people.
[SPEAKER_03]: Their scale mail is ours, but of a different color.
[SPEAKER_03]: And this breastplate that their leader was wearing, he throws it down.
[SPEAKER_03]: It looks like it comes directly out of our forges.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's the same craftsmanship, in fact finer.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I'm gonna look at it, and do I recognize...
[SPEAKER_02]: Any of this from my travels around the islands and like that, is there any markings that call out what it is?
[SPEAKER_02]: Does anybody here speak hobgoblin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Burkoff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Does anybody here speak hobgoblin?
[SPEAKER_00]: Nah, I'm fucking human.
[SPEAKER_00]: Human.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't think I do know human.
[SPEAKER_00]: Can we get any information out of him?
[SPEAKER_03]: If he comes back conscious, we can question him.
[SPEAKER_02]: He'll speak Common better than the others, being that high of a rank.
[SPEAKER_02]: I can try to persuade him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, Bard, do you know any way of sweet-talking creatures before?
[SPEAKER_04]: Not really creatures, but I can try a chance on Common.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm trying to get anything out of him.
[SPEAKER_02]: What's the name of that again?
[SPEAKER_02]: Burkhoff.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where the hell is that?
[SPEAKER_03]: Burkhoff.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'll show you in a minute.
[SPEAKER_03]: You used all your spell slots, didn't you?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes, I did.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is that a long rest or a short rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's a long rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: And Charm Person would be very nice when you're doing that interrogation.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, I could do it.
[SPEAKER_01]: By one way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Real charming.
[SPEAKER_01]: I think we have one prisoner and we don't want to sacrifice any type of lead we have here.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do my spell slots regain after a long rest?
[SPEAKER_03]: So for bards, they only regain after a long rest.
[SPEAKER_03]: A short rest does not give you anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: There are some classes like wizard that can do what's called arcane recovery during short rest, but bards don't do it after 8 hours.
[SPEAKER_01]: What's the weather like?
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't see where my... No, nothing like that.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's looking like it's gonna be a very clear night.
[SPEAKER_03]: A pretty clear night.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't see where my Leon hands comes back after long or short.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't see where it says in here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Do you know this armor?
[SPEAKER_03]: It should say it recovers after a long rest.
[SPEAKER_01]: Please, where's it from?
[SPEAKER_01]: Let us know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or let me know at least.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have no problem telling you.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's Berkhoff armor, but I gotta go with the ADD to figure out where it's from.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here, I'll show you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Come with me.
[SPEAKER_03]: Here's Prince Toli.
[SPEAKER_03]: Berkhoff is this huge land mass over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's the largest part of the Sea Principalities and it's not on the coast.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's like all over here.
[SPEAKER_03]: West Keep is up here and that's like a big inland...
[SPEAKER_03]: But we got that shits all the way up here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, for some reason.
[SPEAKER_03]: And again, the armor is very similar to what the Monmurgans would make.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's just that it's a different kind of look to it, but it's kind of the same sort of style that your country has.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so armorers from my country that are being paid off are true?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, armorers from Burkhoff that have the same kind of style have armed these creatures.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: But what does that play into?
[SPEAKER_02]: I've got to figure out why would they be there?
[SPEAKER_02]: What are they trying to do?
[SPEAKER_02]: What's their purpose?
[SPEAKER_02]: Right.
[SPEAKER_02]: Which is taking prisoners of hire, interrogating, and we've got to try to control the island.
[SPEAKER_02]: We just don't know how many people are on there.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then whatever those fucking shark guys are, that seems like we're okay if we're on land.
[SPEAKER_02]: They'll only go on land if they're forced, which is probably only when their only retreat is that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: So I think we're okay if we stay on high ground.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I recognize it over at all?
[SPEAKER_03]: You recognize it as being something from the Sea Principalities, even though the style is not the same.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, the scale mail looks exactly like your stuff, except that it is a different color, maybe a little bit different stylistically, but the workmanship looks very similar.
[SPEAKER_03]: How do you spell that, Berghoff?
[SPEAKER_03]: Berghoff.
[SPEAKER_03]: B-E-R-G-H-O-F.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are the two dead bodies still up top?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Berkhoff.
[SPEAKER_04]: With us.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: While they're discussing, I'm going to boot the bodies and see if there's anything broken hopeless or understand anything.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, there's the scale now.
[SPEAKER_03]: There is a heavy crossbow if you want to take it and use it.
[SPEAKER_03]: And there are 20 bolts available with it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Now, the question I have is, you can't use martial weapons, can you?
[SPEAKER_02]: Why are people from here martial-like weapons?
[SPEAKER_03]: You have proficiency in simple weapons.
[SPEAKER_02]: Our only choice.
[SPEAKER_02]: You can't use that.
[SPEAKER_03]: So that's probably why you don't have a crossbow off of the beaches.
[SPEAKER_03]: I was just checking more in pockets to see if they had any.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, they have silver coins.
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, you find about 12 silver coins on your beach.
[SPEAKER_03]: Threatens them, and they have no choice in the beach.
[SPEAKER_02]: They can't survive that way.
[SPEAKER_02]: So if we stay on high ground, we'll do a little bit more.
[SPEAKER_04]: What's down there?
[SPEAKER_04]: You guys go through all that stuff.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll let them know what I did after, but I'll... Do you want to split the coinage with the men?
[SPEAKER_03]: With the marines?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, we'll figure it out.
[SPEAKER_04]: But uh...
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, can I go with the lieutenant or sergeant that they were finding, see if he has anything in his pockets that are more prioritized.
[SPEAKER_03]: But under Knight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, he's got a couple of gold coins that are Sea Principality gold mopes.
[SPEAKER_03]: The breastplate that he has is very good.
[SPEAKER_03]: This is medium armor.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't know if you've used medium armor.
[SPEAKER_03]: But this is like a very fine piece of armor.
[SPEAKER_03]: This should add probably something anywhere.
[SPEAKER_03]: You know what I mean?
[SPEAKER_03]: In fact, it's probably where... No, it wouldn't be.
[SPEAKER_02]: This island would have been cleared.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's something that like a noble thing is a captain.
[SPEAKER_03]: No, that should not, no.
[SPEAKER_03]: Worth 400 points.
[SPEAKER_03]: It's very good, it's really good armor.
[SPEAKER_03]: And his sword is fine, good, and all his weapons are really nice.
[SPEAKER_02]: So good, they're creating an army to do something.
[SPEAKER_04]: While I try to persuade the sergeant in, not persuade, but let everyone know that...
[SPEAKER_04]: The armor of the lieutenant is going to go to Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where is Tyrus?
[SPEAKER_02]: Right there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, there he is.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Were you signaling the flame?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yep, I was signaling the flame.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: So, what I'm going to say is this next recording is you guys trying to figure out your next steps.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.